el presidente chino y su homólogo
Vladimir Putin reforzaron su Alianza
Este martes en Moscú los dos jefes de
estado firmaron varios acuerdos de
cooperación
espero mantener estrechos contactos con
el presidente Vladimir Putin en todas
las formas posibles en aras de unas
relaciones chino rusas dinámicas y a
largo plazo
frente a las 11 occidentales
Moscú tuvo que reorientar parte de su
economía hacia su vecino asiático puchin
anunció un acuerdo sobre el proyecto del
gigantesco gasoducto Power cyberiatum
que unirá Siberia con el noroeste de
china
Lo acabamos de discutir es un buen
proyecto el nuevo gasoducto Power
offsiberia tú a través de mongolia casi
todos los parámetros de este acuerdo han
sido confirmados llevará 50.000 millones
de metros cúbicos de gas un suministro
estable de gas desde Rusia la guerra en
Ucrania y el plan de paz chino
estuvieron en el eje de las
conversaciones
por supuesto No ignoramos la situación
en torno a Ucrania creemos muchas de las
disposiciones del plan de paz presentado
por china están en consonancia con los
planteamientos rusos y pueden tomarse
como base para un acuerdo Pacífico
cuando en occidente y en kiev estén
dispuestos a ello sin embargo hasta
ahora no vemos tal disposición por su
parte desde el inicio de la guerra
Beijing adoptó una postura de
neutralidad y nunca condenó la invasión
además su plan de paz no contiene
propuestas concretas para poner fin al
conflicto